This beautiful island is located in East Asia in the northwest Pacific.
Because of its unique landforms, there are rich natural resources.
Here, the climate is warm all year round.
There are beautiful high mountains and blue sea.
Taiwan is a small island,...
...but it is the most interesting and convenient place in the world.
When coming to Taiwan,...
...you will have a chance to experience a different lifestyle,...
...to see spectacular scenery,...
...to taste various authentic and mouth-watering street food...
...and to visit exciting night markets.
You will  also become immersed...
...in Taiwanese passion and hospitality all the time.
This is our Formosa.
If you are planning a trip to East Asia,...
...it's worth visiting for the most touching experience of Taiwan.
Next, let's see one of the most famous landmarks in Taiwan: Taipei 101.
Hey guys!
This is Taipei 101.
It was the tallest building in the world in 2004, and now it is the 8th...
...and it is one of the most famous landmarks in Taiwan.
Every year, there is a fireworks display at the Taipei 101 skyscraper...
...and it is considered the best spot of New Year's celebration.
If you go to the top floor of the building, you can see the entire Taipei City.
The view is spectacular.
And now, let's have a trip to experience the beauty of Taiwan.